hello everyone and welcome back to the a
group of the 20/20 chasuble masters is
the second game between Magnus Carlsen
and Hikaru Nakamura the first game ended
in a draw between the two of them were a
Nakamura had the white pieces and now
Magnus has the white pieces and as a
Nakamura won their previous match across
and will definitely be looking for ways
to get back at him however I don't think
there'll be a triangle that hard as this
is still the preliminary stages of the
tournament and I think they'll be saving
their main weapons for the knockout
phase of the tournament so without
further ado let's check it out it's
quite the game and if you want to do
check it out I will put a link to it in
the description below it will be the
first thing you see Adam and Genesis
made a nice time lapse video of drawing
a portrait of me so if you're interested
in stuff like that do check it out now
getting back into this game Magnus opens
with d4 as he usually does against
Hikaru we have Knight to f6 and now c4
we have e 6 9 12 3 and of course d5 the
Queens gambit declined is on the board
we have Knight to c3 and the Bishop to
e7 and of course Magnus was for his
Bishop to f4 we have castles by Hikaru
and a3 now Knight B to d7 and here
Knight to b5 it's a popular line for for
blitz and rapid games as you are already
attacking the c7 point here so tonight's
the 8 defending it and now just III and
here Nakamura took some three three and
a half minutes the remember you know the
the line how it goes and stuff and in
the end he decided for D characters on
c4 sometimes a six was played before
this capture so you click away the night
but Nakamura decides to go for the
capture first so we have Bishop
characters on c4 so white is very happy
he doesn't have to lose the tempo by
developing a bishop and only then
recapturing what gets the developed by
immediately recapturing and here there
are some games in the database where a
success played or even Knight to d6 but
the movie Nakamura plays is a new move
so already as of mu9 we have a
completely new move
so c5 is on the board going after the
after the center and Magnus captures
here we have D Capra's and c5 he frees
the d4 square for his knight so on a6
doesn't have to retreat the c3 Nakamura
challenges the night and now night back
to d4 instead of C 3 we have Bishop
captures Nakamura recaptures and now
magnus castles to safety we have Queen
to e7 and here it was Magnus we took
quite some time to decide on his next
move maybe some three also maybe maybe
even four minutes and he goes for rook
to c1 he wants to bring the bishop the
back I would say to a2 and the bishop on
a2 will be very strong if you want you
can shift it to not there obviously but
you can shift it to b1 to be used for
attacking purposes and you really want
to free up the C file for your rook so
Bishop to d6 challenging the white
strong dark square bishop and now just
brush it back to a to Magnus played this
very quickly so he knows what the
position is about and here if you
capture here yes you mess up White's
pawns here but it doesn't really matter
you still control the e5 nicely and
after let's say Knight B to f6 or
something you can just go rook e1 and
you still have a very comfortable game
f5 could also be an idea you could
achieve the bishop here again use it for
attack Knight to g5 maybe played so very
very comfortable a position for white
and black still needs to develop the
Queen side so here
Nakamura goes Knight d2 f6 right away
and just Knight to e5 and here again
Nakamura took some time and what you
should do here for black well you could
try a lot of things but g5 looks very
strong here since white cannot capture
the knight would be hanging here you'd
have to go back and then Knight to e4
will challenge the bishop and the black
should get a very comfortable game here
however Nakamura went back as he played
Knight to f6 he now goes back Knight to
d7 and here after a short think Magnus
goes for the for the absolute brilliancy
here but feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the move to solve
the position from the thumbnail while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting that the
Queen doesn't have all that many squares
and the bishop is very vulnerable here
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's Knight d2 c6 and
here blacks entire
just falls apart the problem is well
obviously you can capture the night so
let's explore that first if you capture
the night the other night captures now
threatening the Queen and the Queen has
to leave in the defense of the bishop so
let's say you move Queen to f6 just
Bishop captures here and it's just an
incredibly difficult position to play
for black for example if Knight
characters Queen captures you already
have some threats of 97 check picking up
the bishop and then while removing the
defender of the night just pick it up
and there is no there is no easy way of
defending this and still you don't have
ways of developing the the rook has
nowhere to go
the bishop has nowhere to go since the
knight will be under attack you cannot
play rook d8 since the night covers that
it's just a disgusting position to play
for black so after this Knight d2 c6
move you could try you could try
something else however it's not all that
easy for example you could try moving
the Queen let's say Queen to f6 but it
also doesn't really work because you
will find ways of removing the Queen
from 94 attack the Queen and if Queen g4
trying to go after the night just Bishop
captures here and again after Knight
captures you don't recapture right away
but first 97 check just picking up the
Queen and it's game over so here after
Knight d2 c6 he Kara played Queen to h4
instead he has to try something but now
Magnus continues to go after the Queen
Bishop g3 we have Queen back to g5 and
now again h4 pushing the Queen away from
this dark square diagonal now Queen to
f6
and now finally Knight to g4 and now the
Queen has to move so our Queen captures
on b2 here at least now he this comes
with an attack and the bishop but now
Bishop cat person b6 with an attack on
the rook here and now the problem is if
you go for the bishop first then Knight
East 7 check is extremely strong first
you remove the knight out of out of
harm's way and after King h8 just Queen
captures here again you have the same
threats it doesn't really matter even if
black captures the bishop you can just
pick up the bishop here or just even
rook captures and after characters and
captures you will pick up the knight
finally
this is kind of the theme of the
combination 97 check picks up the bishop
on c8 and you are up a piece of course
completely winning so here after Bishop
captures on d6 Nakamura played beat
captures and c6 first removing this
Knight but this comes with a price of
the exchange
so first Roxy to not allowing the Queen
to capture here Queen back to b5 and
only now rush of captors on f8 and here
Magnus is up the exchange tonight
captures an f8 and now Magnus even goes
for h5 so up material and he goes for
the probably most complicated move here
it's complicated because if the Queen
captures you don't have Knight f6
picking up the Queen since the knight
can capture and the Queen is defended
however after this Queen captures on h5
you do have Queen to d8 and now I mean
who can calculate what's happening here
it's impossible for black to develop I
like if characters they need capture
here and you don't really have all that
all that many options but it is
definitely playable for black however
now camera played h5 he doesn't want to
allow Magnus to continue pushing his
pawn and now Queen to f3 putting
pressure on the c6 pawn and here
Nakamura
does go after the h5 bones so Queen
captures on h5 we have Queen captures on
c6 and now Knight to c7 just getting
getting tonight out of harm's way
hopefully sacrificing this night and
then you want to pick up the denied on
g4 but Magnus just goes back Queen to f3
and now he introduces the threat of rook
captures on c7 but also nice to have 6
check will pick up the Queen now so now
camera goes 95 he covers the f6 square
now again you cannot capture if you
capture it then the Queen will capture
you no longer have any any Knight f6
check threats so instead after Knight to
d5 we have E 4 by Magnus and now it's
all over you cannot move the knight
otherwise Knight f6 chair picks up the
Queen so you might try something like e
5 which is what Nakamura did he opens up
a double attack on the night here but
here Magnus just played the simplest of
moves he played Knight captures on h6
and it was in this position that he
called Nakamura resigned the game
unmoved 28 as there is nothing more to
be
here you cannot capture with the pawn
otherwise you lose the Queen and after
you capture with the Queen or move the
King doesn't really matter you also lose
the Queen so you have to capture with
the Queen to get the Queen out of harm's
way but now after Bishop captures on d5
everything is hanging and there is no
move so the rook is hanging the f7 pawn
is hanging you cannot defend against
both threats if rocked a7 then the
bishop hangs and c8 it's just unplayable
so really really a amazing game and it
it's hard to say why what what happened
here it all comes down to that moment
after this Knight to e5 move kick or
play Knight f6 and then Knight back to
b7 tried to get the Magnus to probably
go back with Knight to f3 or something
but yeah it was probably this g5 and
this is good for black other than that
not really so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
wanna enchant Alvarez Robert theorem al
Alex Wolff Barry bloom and Thomas Dube
and all of you who joined the membership
program like I said we do not have
enough space on the interface but the
argon matter comm is coming so no
worries yeah as usual you can check to
my previous video Sarah thanks for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the 2020
chasuble masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Monday